básicamente estas 11 millones de
personas indocumentadas tendrían que
vivir en eeuu demostrar que pagan
impuestos demostrar que no tienen
problemas con la justicia durante cinco
años para poder aspirar a la green card
el permiso de trabajo una vez tengan la
green card tea tendrían que esperar tres
años más para poder aplicar a la
ciudadanía es decir ocho años en total
para pasar de ser indocumentado a ser
ciudadano estadounidense implica también
esta reforma migratoria más visas para
trabajadores temporales si quieren venir
a eeuu y facilitar las visas a los
familiares hijos esposos esposas que
estén en otros lugares
de fuera de eeuu y que quieran venir a
reunirse con su familia sin embargo se
necesitan 60 votos en la cámara alta
para pasar y ya muchos analistas están
diciendo que esta es una tarea bastante
complicada